الهجمات بالصواريخ والمسيرات الانتحاريه
يراها الغرب علامه على تراجع الروسي في
المعارك على الارض وفي المقابل تحكم روسيا
قبضتها يوما بعد يوم على المقاطعه التي
ضمتها مؤخرا في جنوب اوكرانيا وشرقها فيما
تبقى خرسه مفتاح المواجهه خلال الايام
المقبله
الدلائل كثيره فقد بدات اوكرانيا في تحشيد
قواتها على طقوم خرسون مركزه على المدفعيه
مثل قاذفته هيمارس ومدفعي ام 270
الامريكيين ومادهما 80 كيلو مترا
ومدفعي ام
777 البريطاني الصنع ومده 40 كيلو مترا
هذا المدفع كانت شركه بي اي اي سيستمز قد
اوقفت تصنيعه منذ فتره ولكن تسربت مؤخرا
اشارات عن تفكيرها في تصنيعه من جديد نظرا
للنجاحات التي نتجت عن استخدامه في
اوكرانيا كيف لا تستخدم فقط منظومات
مدفعيه غربيه بل تلقت كذلك دعما من
سلوفاكيا بمدفع سوزانه وبولندا التي قدمت
لكيف مدفع اكراب وكلاه ماذاتي الحركه
روسيا من جهتها مصممه على استراتيجيه
استهداف اكثر البنا التحتيه الاوكرانيه
حيويه وخاصه المتعلقه بالطاقه لاجبار
اوكرانيا على التراجع وحتى الان يثق كل من
الجانبين بقدرته على الحسمه بينما تبتعد
فرص التفاوض العربيه